the og crypto derivatives platform and
the best place to buy your bitcoin
it's time to reveal the honest truth
about andrew tate my name is leah
heilpan and before i get into this video
i do want to let you know that this
particular episode is sponsored by the
cryptocurrency exchange bitmex so if you
want to buy some crypto you want to buy
some bitcoin then pick bitmex so i'm
going to leave the links for you in the
description below so make sure when you
buy your bitcoin or buy your crypto you
pick bitmex i want to make this video to
address the truth about andrew tate i
want to tell you who he is based on my
personal experiences with him we did an
interview together which has actually
got 2.1 million views so if you haven't
seen that i'm gonna leave the card for
you here and also links again in the
description below so definitely check
that out i've actually met andrew on
several occasions the first time i met
him was in 2020 so two years ago we met
in romania in bucharest through a mutual
friend and we all went out for dinner
together he turned up in a lambo which
was pretty cool um he was there with his
girlfriend i was there with some friends
and we all had dinner and we all had a
really really nice time we spoke a lot
about crypto we spoke a lot about covid
we spoke a lot about all the crazy
things that are going on in the world at
the moment he asked me my opinion on it
we had a really nice intellectual
conversation he wasn't rude to me he
wasn't inappropriate with me and he was
very gentlemanly and very friendly we
then ordered some food he said please
order anything you like he was very
polite and friendly to the waiters and
waitresses which i think is also a sign
of somebody's character he got the bill
which was very generous it was obviously
gonna be very expensive we ordered wine
meats starters dessert we had a really
great time a couple days later we were
actually invited to go over to his house
i got to his house and he was very
hospitable very friendly he showed us
around he was very respectful i didn't
feel uncomfortable he was very nice very
friendly he was very funny we spoke a
lot about bitcoin and crypto he told me
about different investments he made i
think in like link or something like
that and everybody was just chatting
having a really nice time we ordered
some drinks we ordered some food he then
went to go play chess on the computer by
himself and we just spoke about
everything and anything he wasn't
inappropriate with me he didn't try
touch me inappropriately or speak with
me inappropriately he just asked me
really about things that i'm interested
in you know and actually one story that
i do really want to recount is they'd
ordered some pizza for us him and his
brother had ordered some pizza i don't
eat pork ham or anything that comes from
a pig and so they ordered pizza with
pepperoni on it and sausages and stuff
like that so i turned around to him i
said hey do you mind i know you've
already ordered it but do you mind
calling the back and ordering something
else i can't eat that he was more than
happy to do that and i felt more than
comfortable asking called them back up
ordered me a margarita pizza and it was
no problem there were some other girls
there they were all having a really nice
time everybody seemed really happy and
like they were enjoying themselves it
was then time to leave and i got an uber
home and that was it so that was two
years ago fast forward to september 2021
we hadn't really spoken but he actually
dropped me a text message saying that he
was going to be in london where i was
based at the time and do i want to come
out and meet him and just catch up so i
actually went to go meet andrew his
brother and some of their friends um in
knightsbridge so i went by myself i got
an uber
and i went to go meet him i decided to
go by myself because i felt fully
comfortable i trusted this person i met
him twice um i've had conversations with
him and i trusted him he was very
gentlemanly he welcomed me i sat next to
him we spoke a lot about my book
actually which he said he was gonna buy
and he never did so that's my only up to
this point that's my only bad thing i
have to say about andrew he said he was
gonna buy my book undressing bitcoin
i'll leave the link in the description
but he hasn't bought it yet but he said
he's going to so andrew you need to buy
my book you promised me other than that
we ordered every he ordered every single
cocktail on the menu he ordered me a
cigar to smoke and never smoked a cigar
before and again we just spoke about the
world we spoke about the last two years
nobody was misogynistic nobody made any
uncomfortable jokes nobody tried again
to touch me inappropriately or anything
like that absolutely not everything was
very nice i felt very comfortable and
his brother had a nice young girl that
was there she seemed very happy like she
was enjoying herself then eventually i
decided that i wanted to go home and
andrew walked me out got up like a
gentleman brought me to the front of the
building and he ordered me an uber home
and he ordered me an xxl executive the
most over-the-top extravagant uber there
is he paid for it and he said to the
uber driver this is my wife please make
sure you look after her make sure she
gets home safely otherwise he'd have him
to deal with i thought that was very
very nice um he was being very gentle
money making sure that i got home safely
which is totally different and in
contrast to what social media is saying
about him they're saying that he hates
women he abuses women and clearly none
of that is true in my personal
experience so far i've been with him
alone with his brothers and
nothing negative has happened i've
always felt very protected and very
comfortable and he texted me to make
sure that i got home okay andrew says
that women are the most precious things
on the planet and they need to be
protected and that certainly felt true
it felt like he really meant what he
said so that was september 2021 so fast
forward to december 2021 um i'm in miami
he's in miami and he drops me a message
and he says hey let's do an interview so
i actually got an uber to his place to
his house where he was staying in miami
um again i went by myself and i felt
very comfortable to go by myself and i
was right i get to his place um and then
andrew's just there around the corner
and he says hi and everything was very
nice um and actually he had this um he
had professional catering staff so
they'd actually laid out like a long
table in the kitchen of fruits there was
granola yogurts there was croissants
coffee tea everything looked really
delicious um and he offered me some
breakfast which was nice we kind of
discussed the questions that we were
gonna talk about now i wanted to do the
interview with him because he has a lot
of controversial opinions and there's a
lot that i agreed with him on in the
interview there's parts that i disagreed
with him on which i kind of mentioned
but overall i was very open-minded and
happy to do the interview because i
really wanted to learn more about him
okay so the first controversial comment
which a lot of people don't like that he
said in the interview was he compared
women to children now i think a lot of
what andrew says is hyperbole and i
think it's exaggerated and it's simply
just an analogy no he doesn't literally
think women are children if you thought
women were children he wouldn't be
sleeping with women he's basically
saying women are not men women are
delicate women are emotional women need
help whether it's emotional support
whether it's physical support you know
we need attention and all of these
things i agree with him he said that
women are difficult to travel with and i
understand that you know we get hungry
and if we're not fed we get hungry so i
understand when he says women are
children we're emotional we need
emotional support and i think the older
i get the more i value men the more i
understand how men can provide stability
emotional stability they're that anchor
to reality which i think women really
need but like i said you got to take
what he says with a pinch of salt he's a
marketer it's hyperbole it's going to be
exaggerated okay the second point is the
whole thing about monogamy he says when
you're a high value man you can have as
many women as you want now i agree i
don't necessarily think this is ethical
or unethical but i think it's true you
see some of the mo richest most
successful men in the world they have
multiple women because they can now
here's the distinction and the important
point to make if all the women involved
know the truth they know the deal they
know what's going on then i think it's
fine my pushback was he was sort of
saying that you know all men are this
way i don't think he can talk all men
with the same brush i think that would
be unfair he can't speak for all men
obviously but like he also says
exceptions don't make rules so the rule
is if you're super high value you're the
man that every single woman wants then
yes you can have multiple women and the
women will be okay with that there are
other things that i disagreed with him
on but overall it doesn't really matter
because at the end of the day we're
having a conversation and just because i
may disagree with him on something it
doesn't mean that i have to be offended
it doesn't mean that he's being sexist
it doesn't mean that he's being
misogynistic doesn't mean that he's
being an abuser it just means we
disagree and we can't disagree because
we're adults now i want to address the
rumors and the misconceptions now one of
the most controversial things that um
keeps going around and a lot of my
friends are actually texting me saying
um is leia how can you justify andrew's
opinion whereby andrew says women are my
property now are women the property of
men it's a great question now again i
think that statement is hyperbole i
think that it's an exaggeration of um a
greater sentiment essentially in that
it's the man's responsibility to
provide for her to lead her to protect
her that's sort of why he would say
women are a man's property you don't
have to be offended by it it's also not
a new concept either it's why the father
walks the woman down the aisle when she
gets married it's always going to be a
man that walks the woman down the aisle
and gives her over to her husband since
the dawn of time women have been men's
property but not in a negative way in a
way that it's the man's responsibility
to always look after her always provide
for her always to make sure she's okay
she's safe i think that's beautiful i
think we're trying to be offended by
something which actually is a very
beautiful concept in fact the kind of
man that i'm looking for is a man that
would also consider me to be his
property because when i'm his property
he's gonna make sure nothing bad happens
to his property the same way a man
protects his car his house his family is
the same way that i hope that my husband
one day will protect me another really
controversial topic is the fact that
andrew talks about liking younger girls
now a lot of these clips that we see of
andrew have actually been taken out of
context so when he talks about younger
girls we're not talking about women who
are younger than 18 and i don't think
he's ever said that i've never heard
andrew say he's into young girls he's
talking about women in their 20s as
opposed to women in their 30s and 40s
and there's nothing wrong with that how
can you be offended by somebody's sexual
preference and this is nothing new
either i think a lot of this stuff with
andrew he's saying what everybody else
is thinking men since the dawn of time
of preferred younger women for whatever
reason and that's okay women have always
dated older men nobody's ever had a
problem with that the kind of man that
i'm looking for is a man that's going to
be in his 30s because i need certain
things and i know that i'm more likely
to find that in a man in his 30s i
remember when i was growing up and i was
19 20 21 and i'd be wanting a man that
was 25 26 and the men my own age would
be really hurt and offended by that and
there's nothing you can do about that i
didn't like guys my own age the same way
men don't like women their own age they
date down women date up this is just
reality and it's not a big deal and i
think actually andrew is doing a great
good for women and for feminism i think
andrew's actually the greatest feminist
if you think about it and i've actually
texted andrew and i told him women girls
that are 15 years old um in 10 years
time will have will have a big thank you
to say to andrew because the guys that
are currently 25 are consuming his
content and learning how to be a man you
know what does it mean to be a man what
does it mean to protect and provide
forget toxic masculinity andrew's
actually teaching men how to be men when
these 15 year olds turn 25 and they're
looking at men that are 35 you know
they're gonna have better men to pick
from because they've learned from andrew
to wrap up i think there's a massive war
on masculinity right now to really show
this war and masculinity across media
outlets they're talking about you know
if a man wants to work out and he's got
muscles it means he's he's a right wing
and he's probably going to be sexist and
a misogynist i mean what the hell is
that the government this system they
want you weak they want men particular
to be weak fat and compliant so that
they can't fight the tyranny because
when you're weak fat and compliant um
addicted to porn and unable to get
outside your house and actually be aware
of what's going on in the world then the
powers that be have more control when
men are strong when men are intelligent
when men are entrepreneurs where men are
hitting the gym that is not good for
those who are in charge and so like i
said earlier i'm personally very excited
about what andrew's doing and he's
empowering men to be better as a woman i
want a strong man i want a man that's
going to look after me and only a strong
man who knows how to take personal
responsibility somebody that's wise
somebody that's smart only that kind of
man is going to be able to do that a lot
of women are settling for men that
aren't particularly strong because there
aren't strong men left and so women are
miserable women are then having to
become more masculine so they can fill
that void that's been created by society
because men aren't men anymore i think
femininity can truly flourish in an
environment whereby she's safe and
safety is masculinity it's masculine
energy it's um showing her that
everything's going to be okay you know
solving problems for her that is how
femininity can truly flourish and so
when a man can be a man as andrew's
empowering them to be then a woman can
be a woman
and that makes me happy so overall to
wrap up this video i have had nothing
but positive encounters with andrew tate
he's always been very gentlemanly i
think he's very fun he's very
charismatic and he's very smart i think
he's a great businessman he's also let
me say i haven't mentioned this yet he's
also loyal he's loyal to his friends
he's loyal to his brothers and that is a
huge sign of somebody's character
there's a lot of accusations about him
online and honestly i just don't believe
them because i've met the guy and
because i don't believe them i will meet
andrew again
and we will do another podcast again
guys if you did enjoy this video please
don't forget to hit the like button and
hit subscribe so you never miss a video
so you can stay up to date and actually
help support this kind of content
because right now as we saw censorship
is absolutely rife i don't agree with it
i don't support censorship i support
freedom of speech and on this channel i
try to push as much freedom of speech as
possible give everybody a platform so if
you can all please hit the like button
and subscribe i'd appreciate that and we
can keep spreading this message until
next time stay tuned the leia hill plan
show
you